what we will attempt to start to do in
this video is take the surface integral
take the surface integral of the
function x squared over our surface
where the surface in question the
surface we're going to care about is
going to be the unit sphere so it could
be defined by x squared plus y squared
plus Z squared is equal to 1 and what
I'm going to focus on in this first
video because it will take us several
videos to do it it's just a
parameterization of this surface right
over here and as you'll see this is
often the hardest parts it takes a
little bit of visualization and then
after that it's kind of mechanical but
it can be kind of hairy at the same time
so it's worth going through so first
let's just think about how we can
parameterize and I have trouble even
saying the word how we can parameterize
this unit sphere as a function of two
parameters so let's think about it let's
think about it a little bit so first
let's just think about let's just think
about the unit sphere I'm gonna take a
side view of the unit sphere so let's
take the unit sphere so this right over
here is our z-axis that's our z-axis and
then over here I'm going to draw this is
going to be not just the X or the y axis
this is going to be the entire XY plane
viewed from the side that is the X the X
Y plane now our sphere our sphere our
unit sphere might look something like
this the unit sphere itself is not too
hard to visualize it might look
something like that the radius let me
make it very clear the radius at any
point is 1 so this length right over
here is 1 that length right over there
is 1 and this is a sphere not just a
circle so I could even shade it in a
little bit just to make it clear that
this thing has some dimensionality to it
so that's shading it in it's kind of
makes it look a little bit more
spherical
now let's attempt to parameterize this
and there's a first step let's just
think if we didn't have to think above
and below the XY plane if we just
thought about where this unit sphere
intersected the XY plane how we could
parameterize that so let's just think
about it so where intersects the XY
plane intersect
there and there and actually everywhere
so it intersects it right over there so
let's just draw the XY plane and think
about that intersection then we could
think about what happens as we go above
and below the XY plane so on the XY
plane this little region where we where
we just shade it in so let me draw so
this is so now you could view this as
almost a top view the z-axis is now
going to be pointing straight out at you
straight out of the screen so that's X
let me draw it so that's X and then this
right over there is Y so this thing that
we were viewing sideways now we're
viewing it from the top and so now our
unit sphere is going to look is going to
look something like this viewed from
above and this what I just drew this
dotted circle right over here this is
going to be where our unit sphere
intersects what I would label that Y
that should be X don't want to confuse
you already let me clear that so this is
our x-axis this is our x-axis so this
little dotted blue circle this is where
our unit sphere intersects the XY plane
and so using this we can start to think
about how to parameterize at least our x
and y values our x and y coordinates as
a function of a first parameter so the
first parameter we can think of
something that is so this is the z-axis
popping straight out at us so we're
essentially if we're rotating around
that z-axis viewed from above we could
imagine an angle an angle and I'll call
that angle I will call that angle s
which is essentially saying how much
we're rotating from the x axis towards
the y axis in you could think about it
in the XY plane or in a plane that is
parallel to the XY plane or you could
say going around the z axis z axis
popping straight up at us and the radius
here is always 1 it's a unit sphere
so given this parameter s what would be
your X&Y coordinate our thinking about
it right if we're sitting in the XY
plane well the x coordinate this goes
goes back to the unit circle definition
of our trig functions the x coordinate
is going to be cosine of s it would be
the radius which is 1 times the cosine
of s and the y-coordinate
would be one times the sine of s that's
actually where we get our definitions
for cosine and sine from so that's
pretty straightforward and in this case
Z is obviously equal to zero so if we
wanted to add our Z coordinate here Z is
0 we are sitting we are sitting in the
XY plane but now let's think about what
happens if we go above and below the XY
plane remember this is this is in any
plane that is parallel to the XY plane
this is saying how we are rotated around
the z-axis now let's think about if we
go above and below it and to figure out
how far above or below it I'm going to
introduce another parameter and this new
parameter I'm going to introduce is T T
is how much we have rotated above and
below the XY plane now what's
interesting about that is if we take any
other cross-section that is parallel to
the XY plane now we are going to have a
smaller radius let me make that clear so
if we if we if we're this if we're right
over there
if we're right over there now where this
plane intersects our unit sphere the
radius is smaller the radius is smaller
than it was before well what would be
this new radius well a little bit of
trigonometry a little bit of
trigonometry it's the same as it's the
same as this length right over here
which is going to be cosine so it's
going to be cosine of T so the radius
the radius is going to be cosine of T
and it still works over here because if
T goes all the way to 0 cosine of 0 is 1
and then that works right over there
when we're in the XY plane so the radius
the radius over here is going to be so
that is right over there is cosine of 0
so this is when T this is when T is
equal to zero and we haven't rotated
above or below the XY plane but if we
are if we have rotated above in the X Y
above the XY plane the radius has
changed it is now cosine of T and now we
can use that to truly parameterize X&Y
anywhere so now let's look at this
cross-section so where you could you
were not necessarily the XY plane we're
in something that's parallel to the XY
plane and so if we're up here now all of
a sudden the cross section if we viewed
it if we
view it from above might look something
like this it might look something
something like this we're viewing it
from above this cross-section right over
here our radius our radius right over
here is cosine cosine of T and so given
that I guess altitude that we're at what
would now be the parameterization using
s of x and y well it's the exact same
thing except now that I've written
except now our radius isn't a fixed one
it is now a function of T so we're now a
little bit higher so now our our
x-coordinate our x-coordinate is going
to be our radius which is cosine of t
cosine of t that's just our radius x
times cosine of s times cosine of s how
much we've angled around and in this
case in this case s has gone all the way
around here s has gone all the way
around there so it's going to be cosine
of T times cosine of s and then our
y-coordinate is going to be our radius
which is cosine of T times sine of s
same exact logic here except now we have
a different radius our radius is no
longer 1 times sine of s sine of s
running out of space let me scroll to
the right a little bit and then and this
looks very confusing but you said to say
at any given level we are we're parallel
to the x axis we're kind of tracing out
another circle where another plane
intersects our unit sphere we're now
then rotating around with s and so our
radius will change it's a function of
how much above and below we've rotated
how much above or below the xy-plane
we've rotated so this is just our radius
instead of 1 and then s is how much
we've rotated around the z-axis same
there for the y-coordinate and then the
z coordinate is pretty straight forward
it's going to be full it's going to be
completely a function of T it's not
dependent on how much we've rotated
around here at any given at any given
altitude it is what our altitude
actually is and we can go straight to
this diagram right over here our Z
coordinate is just going to be the sine
of T so there Z Z is equal to
of T so let me write that down so Z is
going to be equal to sine of T so now
every point on the sphere sphere can be
described as a function of T and s and
we have to think about over what range
will they be defined well s is going to
go at any given level you could think
for any given T s is going to go all the
way around we see that right over here
at any given level viewed from above s
is going to go all the way around so
thinking about it in radians s is going
to be between 0 and 2pi and T is
essentially our altitude in the Z
direction so T can go all the way down
here which would be negative PI over 2
so T can be between negative PI over 2
and it can go all the way up to PI over
2 it doesn't need to go all the way back
down again and so goes all the way back
I always goes up to PI over 2 and then
we have our prior ammeter is a ssin let
me write this down in a form that you
might recognize even more if we wanted
to write our surface as a position
vector function we could write it like
this we could write it R is a function
of s and T and it is equal to our our X
component our I component is going to be
cosine of T cosine of T cosine of s
cosine of s I and then plus our Y
component is cosine of T cosine of T
sine of s sine of s plus our Z component
which is the sine which is just oh I
forgot our J vector J plus the Z
component which is just sine sine of T
sine of T K and we're done and this is
and these are the ranges that those
parameters will take on so that's just
the first step we've parameterised this
surface now we're going to have this
actually set up the surface integral
it's going to involve a little bit of
taking a cross product which can get
hairy and then we can actually evaluate
the integral itself